welcome to this video round for action
of the candidates tournament in
countyman disk and we have Mahmoud yar
off against under akin this game will be
examined examined in this video yeah
looking at the name sent the tournament
standing the citizen doesn't really
sound like him
totally great game er of his on - - and
and raking on - one so they both have
somewhat disappointing tournament
they both certainly hoped for more
despite the fact that they are not
exactly favourites in the field but
still if you have prepared for a long
time which they certainly what they
certainly did you sort of have have more
hopes for your performance than being on
the bottom end of the the tournament
table okay let's see what happens
Gareth played before and he's got the
third times 2/3 times white in this
tournament which does not really make
his performance look any any better to
be honest and he gets Slav again the
third game at this one third time he'll
he faces Slav defense really it's really
a lot on Drake eNOS a flexible play a
play so many lines against e4 and down
it's again a Slav let's see what remedy
our F is coming up this time
midnight c3 yet plate four two times
already in the stone he played once this
line drawing against Apollo and Queen c2
losing against talent and now he's going
for something entirely different
starting with Knight c3 yeah that's an
interesting news order that has some
some points in comparison with Knight f3
one point is that after Knight f6 very
normal move
there's the move III which
was mamuro's choice actually the idea is
now that you have gone into this III
type of systems where you actually make
it more difficult for black to play
Bishop f5 some time ago I would have
said that sort of more difficult to
almost prevent the move but nowadays
it's not it's not so clear what I'm
getting at is that here Bishop and five
is answered by the capture and Queen b3
and for years it was thought that black
is in bad shape here b7 is saying and d5
is hanging so move like Queen b6 normal
looking and just loses a pawn so sorry
this was there this was stupid so you
should have five takes takes so it was
thought that black actually must play
Bishop c8 all the way back and this is
not terribly exciting but then with the
help of modern analysis engines it was
found out that knight c6 is actually an
interesting move sacrificing a pawn
funny enough within retreat 37 this
seems to be a sufficient compensation
for black and was even recommended in
this recently released book by famous
author and theoretician Borissov rook so
this is a big sign of approval if he
thinks that this is a decent line so
Bishop f5 is an interesting move to go
nowadays and this is entirely different
to the position where the night is on f3
because they are the pressure on d5 is
um it's not so effective yeah okay
Mandrake and played a6 this just also
well-known Knight f3 and tae played a 6
yeah we have a very flexible position
here black has other ways to go we are
in the chavín n course laughs now
characterized by this a six move the
original shavon anchor movers but has
lost some of its popularity I believe
mostly because after c5 white seems to
retain a slight slight pressure there
also as Bishop f5 which is a good move
played by cards and amongst others and
also recommended by a broker in the book
that I was referring to an important
point of the whole setup with a success
that after move like Queen b3 like
actually has this funky rook move it's a
very good actually
a seven to cover the pawn it looks a bit
strange I know but black here very often
will just repair this issue by by later
covering a b7 with the Queen for example
and then retreating the rook again note
that the Queen on b3 is also not ideal
as sometimes you want to be born in the
action but this did happen and regulate
a6 so many alternatives a 3e 6 by the
way was played by Arnold in his version
which should match against Gale front a
couple of times also an interesting move
yeah
a3 now we are off this is rare really
rare move and after 97 that Queen c2
yeah here under waking up late at least
for me a surprising move we played Queen
c7 Here I am thought that black would
simply play the capture on c4 and I well
I don't know the position but I thought
that this should be quite ok and did it
it seems that tournament practice
confirms that this is a viable option
the idea is to quickly get going with v5
and c5 let's say here yeah or a - I
don't know and then c5
which is very similar to the Queens
gambit accepted the structure but with
the Queen White Queen on c2 I don't
really believe that
why should have a haven here and it
would have been interesting to see what
idea and Omidyar of had prepared
he certainly prepared to this line with
a three and Queen c2 maybe not
specifically for unbreaking but it's
well known that while an ant has played
it in a world championship match this
line and it's always possible that this
position might occur in any game in this
tournament so it would have been
interesting but don Rican played as
mentioned Queen c7 and look they both
spent quite quite some time and Drake in
taking lots of Tonia and the Queen c7
it's it's feels a bit weird to me but
who came amid yar event for Eve for a
central strike central play this in fact
has gotten more interesting now in the
position after y displayed a three very
often I have to taste it no sorry I keep
hitting this instead of this after this
sorry in this in this position very
often like standard counter plays Bishop
before but now with a three played this
obviously not possible
black likes to exchange one one pair of
bishops and well that's not on anymore
he played c5 here to free his position
and a white cap shirt and took on c5
it's a bit difficult to play something
else you don't really want to do that
because you develop blacks Bishop in one
move but how actually what else to do I
mean the problem is white wants to
fianchetto and if you start with g3
black is going to take and while this is
just
not helping in any way therefore white
captured and after 85 when G 3 a 5 yeah
it's a playable move of course this also
was possible but he probably didn't like
the look of before and possibly C 5 I
understand that so a 5 g 3 Bishop c5
yeah black has weakened the blue v
square a bit but this is not relevant as
the knight is so far away from it should
G 2 black cancelled to White Castle
yeah here we have a critical position
and rakin now as a choice or he has to
address one important issue and this is
what to do against Bishop to f4 this is
the logical developing that white maybe
is going to play and let's say you play
Bishop d7 now just a normal move to
complete development I think then Bishop
f4 leads to a slight advantage for white
if black moves the Queen that's 95 and
this is the issue white wants to fight
for this e5 square for Knight and the
knight on e5 in combination with the
bishop is really a yes the trump card
for white if you go back you can play
this but it gives up even more time
let's say here here
Andrew key one intending 95 even in a
position like that white is slightly
more comfortable because of this very
nice Knight only 5 blackest of course a
decent chances it's not like he's lost
or anything but it always feels a bit
uncomfortable to allow this Knight to
arrive on e5 he simply put an end to all
that
by playing D 5 himself what that also of
course has the benefit of allowing the
LightSquared bishop to be developed it
looks perfectly normal to smooth but it
has some
vacations that are far-reaching right
now played Bishop g5 and maybe intends
to take on f6 to win black's pawn
structure
yeah and reckon played rook a6 now to
allow a possible recapture by the rook
now Luke a e1 was played yeah
intensifying pressure on this pawn the
five point is something that white can
can easily attack with the night the
rook and even with the Queen soon enough
and this is why I was emphasizing that
if five is a far-reaching decision if
you look at what happens now I played
rupee eight and Queen c3 I'm mentioning
that what yeah intensifies the pressure
what is blacks move now to avoid just
losing a pawn and this is the problem
it's very tricky now you cannot really
prevent white from from spoiling your
pawn structure with Bishop f6 g6 GT xf 6
mm or think about that but is this a
good position before and c5 coming it
just looks very clumsy and if you defend
like that white can also take and I get
to this pawn structure the problem as
usual are not the pawns itself that they
are weak or something but it's their
weakened they are squares weakened and
this also applies to the gaim
continuation when Drake and just played
age six and yeah just let er of take so
we have this pawn structure which of
course as mentioned is leaving some weak
squares but in black
skimp but on the other hand the position
also has some qualities of exposition
yes a foothold in the center with this
strong e5 pawn his king is not in a big
problem
at the moment I mean why this not really
positioned to to drum up a quick King
side attack based on pieces and the
other white of course needs to be aware
of black has the bishop pair which is a
long-term long-term asset so the
position is some may be about equal
maybe in this is the fair evaluation but
I feel and this applies through the
upcoming part of the game I feel that
it's easier for white to play to be
honest I very much would prefer white
yeah I mean it's still you know if you
know my channel you know I have a
terrible bishop pair addiction but this
is it feels like it's easier for white
white has some some easier play that he
can that he can initiate let's look for
let's look at the next couple of moves
before played and sorry it was too quick
bishop f8 was played he also could have
taken but probably and rake in thought
ever can take any way at any point on
before so he just retreated to f8 which
that was not good which adds some
protection on possibly for the king and
well you don't really want to go to g7
on last year you need to but it's a
possible way to defend the king black
wants to pressurize still the screen
side so Bishop evade the Sun or move and
now Knight h4 yeah the night does not
really have a great square besides one
this is a five of course
so not h4 s perfectly
logical now he took and played Bishop to
e6 you know okay c4 has attacked South
Yarra off advances c4 c5 yet here we
come to an absolutely critical position
and this is one of those positions where
I believe that black simply has a very
difficult task in a practical game it's
a big difference if you look at this at
home maybe even assisted by by a
computer playing it over the board with
limited time it seems that black has
some some problems to solve the computer
is pretty much unimpressed it's always
about equal of 0.2 for white and now
nothing terribly special of right inning
but I'm not so sure really how black
should defend now what he does is he
plays a very debatable move I believe at
least he played the move B 6 and after B
6 right of course as C 5 as attacked
advances to C 6 and this means that was
B 6 blackest has just given white and an
enormous pawn on c6 a passed pawn but he
has got of course has gotten some things
in in return he has activated the f8
bishop which now attacks the somewhat
weak before fall and yeah well it sits
on c6 yeah but it's not like white is
promoting it to a queen quickly in the
next couple of moves so it's it's not
100% clear that b6 is a mistake but I
feel I don't have a good feeling about
this move I'm a summer same if you look
at the the further course of the game
you can invest really lots of
time to analyze it I have invested a bit
of time and it's not so clear to me how
to correctly evaluate this b6 movie I
just feel that it's it's making blacks
task more difficult than what was
necessary at least I believe my
suggestion to to not play b6 would and
the water what what am I suggesting is
rube f88 just not move the b-pawn the
idea is still to enter with the rookie I
activated on the fr and just a void to
move the b-pawn of course the thing is
it's always under attack by this g2
Bishop so it's not like it sits very
comfortably sitting on b7 this is also
one reason for b6 that black is not yeah
it's not word must not very many more
about the b7 pawn yeah in this line if
we continue for a bit white can try many
things he can play prophylactic moves
like would be one we will see some of
that in the game and after Luke is free
maybe Quincy to to intend to Knight f5
long white can play much more directly
with Queen f3 attacking here and
attacking here the remarkable thing is
that black can actually allow white to
take on b7
maybe in this line and Dracon wasn't
trusting of the position it's very
important very much possible I think
it's very very difficult to play all
this route k3 is actually the key move
and one simple point is that this blonde
does the Queen so white will take on b7
I guess otherwise it really didn't
help very much yo I just takes it and
yeah possible line is this takes takes
and now Luke v8 which will regain the
pawn it looks really dangerous to be
honest with the poor nev white play see
six black takes here however and it's
not apparent how white is going to
promote this pawn I mean this Bishop on
b7 is very much reduced to just to cover
the pawn and black very often will just
pay Bishop d6 to cover them cooperate c7
square and of course there's also a
bishop on e6 so you can almost never win
with c7 yeah like like this like it
captures tradition this is actually a
position that seems to be completely
okay for black at least when I was
trying a bit with the computer and
having never got anywhere it gives it a
zero zero zero anyway and even any I
tried a bit like getting the night over
but never led to anything it's just
always zero zero zero no in this it was
a playable alternative to not play b6
but he did b6 c6 and now look a for
attacking the pawn here instead of a
rook a form black also could have played
here Luke a8 but I'm not sure if it is
an improvement actually white probably
again should reflect a clique cover the
before bonus there will be attacks
coming yeah and here yeah tricky maybe a
move like b5 who black before b5 I'm not
sure that you want to see that now
Kyrenia three and possibly Queen e2 to
cover to attack b5 at the right moment
and the computer is not so much
impressed about all this it gives many
of those positions as about equal but
really is it easy to play so black I
really don't know I would have very much
prefer white here you have so many
annoying looking ideas let's say also
something like that might be interesting
attending here here Knight a5 black
quickly must get counter play against
this type of idea otherwise what will be
just much much better its and I feel in
a practical game why this has has a much
easier job yam okay rook a fourth look
to be won and rudi edge yeah intending
to activate you on 24th
yeah Queen f3 just looking at the pawn
here maybe white can can grab it and
here he also could could people played
Bishop before this is this was my idea
when I was watching the game life sort
of getting getting both pieces involved
for f5 or their five square and it it
seems to be a decent alternative it's
not clear if it's any better or worse in
this this complicated positions if you
have an idea I'm always glad to get to
not blunder too much can easily happen
well rook default Queen f3 this was some
the idea that that I had and though I
it's it seems playable it seems like a
play will complicated position Blackie I
can grab here and here interestingly
enough the computer um wants to play
what does it want to play do you want I
think now look a one
attending UK aid yeah it's it's an
interesting position very very unclear
in the game we played Queen f3 which is
okay I believe look to deform activating
the rook Knight f5 this was the idea all
along you need to use the weakened
squares yeah black took this pawn which
seems seems right seems correct and now
Queen to h5 attacking the h6 bone yeah
white is a pawn down but he's got so
yeah his pieces are so active yeah the
Queen here the knight the bishop is
strong and the rook might joined the
action soon it's clear that white has an
excellent compensation for the pawn okay
the queen is on h5 what did she do we
played King to h7 sensibly covering h6
lucrative one and queen c8
yeah note the clock times they both were
down to 13 minutes and this is a no
increment time control so they have
roughly one minute per move for the
remaining 11 moves yeah this is a tech
jam need to retreat 93 not a bad thing
this retreat is not not a big problem or
anything yeah it's here we have a very
sorry a very critical position where it
seems that unbreaking made a mistake but
it's some very very tricky this position
and in fact I believe that both players
have played a really good game I mean up
to this point if you if you check it
with the computer it is very complicated
and they didn't commit any substantial
mistakes at least nothing that that
that I could find or the engine could I
could find you can always argue about
some move being more accurate or
something but considering the the
complexity of the position I think they
did an excellent job
yeah here and Drake in plate as I
mentioned to f5 and this doesn't seem to
to be good really a computer recommends
look before as a defense but it must be
said that if you look at this position
this is something that the computer just
believes to be equal but play that over
the board it's not much fun I can assure
you that something like f5 and possibly
not therefore it's just not fun to play
for black you you have a pawn but you
don't have a particularly great King
White has good pieces yes the C pawn and
it's not clear what blacks play is this
is easily defended and it's not like you
quickly can can can run with the b-pawn
as White has even direct attacking ideas
so examples for example something like
that is an interesting way to play my
captures take check and try to initiate
an attack on the light squares you still
have excellent excellent compensation
yeah well he played f5 roopd form would
have led to an unclear position let's
call it let's call it that but f5 seems
to give white something so something
substantial for the first time and he
found the right move he found Bishop d4
d5 the idea being to capture and enter
on the seventh just a very strong yeah
black does not have much of an
alternative to f4 he played f4 directly
pushing the pawn yeah the the point is
of course that if white now takes it
takes is still a very decent defense
something like night
five rooks e4 isn't clear at all it's
it's very tricky to play but black is in
perfectly acceptable shave him Knight c2
is stronger rupee form
yeah not much else okay four and now I
played Queen takes d5 so this pawn got
lost but it's it's not not such a big
deal the porn itself the problem is
concrete tactics Bishop g7 yeah and here
we come to the point where both players
are down on time member dro three
minutes 40 and and rakin was about about
the same just about a minute more and
here nobody are off invested quite some
time and played check bishop Eve what
check it's a very very complicated
affair of course you can easily see that
the calculation process here is not
something you can easily do with a
little time it turns out that in the
cold light of the engine evaluation that
Bishop e-form
seems to give away the advantage but
very very tricky
yeah the computer wants to play Queen to
d6 just keeping White's trumps I mean
why term simply has the strong pawn and
black this in this position does not
really have anything better than to take
and White has a very nice dominating
position here it's not so easy to say
what's the most um
the most tenacious defense here maybe
Queen to e6 after the capture however
it's a very strong pawn here this the C
pawn and look at this very important
tactic tending Knight takes c6 yeah
black black has a tough defense here
it's
it's it's very close to being to being
lost to be honest but not not easy to
say if it's really a loss or just very
hard to defense but 96 is Queen to d6 is
the way to go
however we should you I mean it looks
like perfectly normal move and it's of
course very sharp and very easy to miss
calculate what actually did happen there
should be four check and now Queen g8 if
you look at this now you see that okay
the queen is attacked and the rook is
attacking the bishop as well so what
should we do took on f4 this was the
idea and so far certainly expected by
Mohammed Arif and Dracon played f5
setting up this this pin on the Queen
so does he just win a piece now could
think that this is the case but he has
c7 the important reply initiating on
introducing this idea route d8 check
yeah
and Reagan took only form pretty quickly
anything else does not make much sense
check and now look the a check
yeah and here in this position if you
want you can treat this position as a
calculation exercise if you want to sort
of get the feeling of how it is to play
in an important event and enduring a
complicated position with real time you
see under-18 has three minutes left
yeah this is pretty precise this is
pretty precise I saw the original video
footage um he had a little bit less I
believe a little bit less time not much
though maybe two minute 40 or something
if you want let's say take yourself two
minutes and try to calculate the the
consequences here what what happens yeah
you see that it's a check and black only
has three feasible
to think about Bishop 8 we have seven
teenage them those are the three move
that you need to check the capture of
courses check is just too easy
so three moves to consider you have got
two minutes try to work out the lines
I'll be silent for just a couple of
seconds so that you can easily pause the
video if you like alright so I hope you
took some time because it's interesting
to figure out the intricacies of this
position it turns out that let's start
with the easy one
Bishop f8 is not good it's in fact
immediately losing you to Queen takes h6
this is some I guess easy to see now
Queen takes ages threatened and black
has no music and easily resign him so
it's the King news but where do you go
to f7 or to h7 in fact the initial idea
probably is maybe King f7 for most
people because the king is covering this
this Bishop and it's not apparent what
what's the problem with this move might
be this is in fact what Andre can plate
and it's the wrong one that's actually
the move that loses the game by now we
we had this in the stage where black can
save himself with King age 7 this is why
Bishop before check wasn't precise
exactly the moves that were played in
the game are the best ones chant here
Andre can can can secure the draw with
King h7 which she didn't do the
difference the key thing is okay the
queen is attacked he needs to go to d6
and black will play Queen a six year
this is perfectly logical and there is
simply a big difference to the king
position on f7 here
yeah being different to the f7 position
of the King here there's no route d7
check this is simply a useless smooth
black takes here there's no check and
Ruby form make sure that the C pawn is
not promoting blackest relatively easily
winning here this is hanging but check
it's just one check and nothing more
the problem with and rakin smoothness
the following and this happened in the
game Queen d6 Queen a6 and now check
discern and this is the the problem what
he probably miss misjudged to some
extent he played king of some relatively
quickly I just I just saw that here wow
that's a bad mistake
yeah I didn't I didn't have a clear
recollection of that authority
he took took some time time IAM how
that's awful really
you have three I mean not it's not like
criticism
I'm just feeling the pain because you
have three minutes and I mean that's not
terribly much but you only need here
maybe like a minute or sort of fear that
this is critical and I mean he obviously
knew it was critical it's looking at the
position tells you that but it's just
here he knew he could have saved himself
but king f7 is just running right into
that and Mahmud Yara found it easily
this is nonsense the mind is something
he made the time control with a couple
of seconds on the clock
rook d7 check yeah and the problem is
simply if you take check you know you
will have the Queen neck smooth I can
even catch it yeah and then then there's
a note with an easy win yeah
so you need to move the king he went to
g6 a nominee dr of played queen c6
simple and strong with a prepare sociate
queen and black has no reply to that
that's that's it not difficult if you
move the King for example I just I just
promote and what is the queen up against
the rock yeah in the game he played
Queen c8 now barely making the time
control and mamedyarov played rook ta ta
really quickly in a couple of seconds he
had 40 minutes if what he moves made and
knew that but he still played rook to e8
quickly because it's yeah it's very
apparent that this is no winning with c8
coming note that this pin is so ugly if
black plays here you know you you cannot
I cannot even take the rook it's just
it's just this pin being the problem
yeah and raking plate Roxy for that's a
final move and ya Mahmud Arif just
captured it and after that and raking
resigned the game Bishop c4 rook c8 is
suggest a complete when you get a new
Queen even quickly so one can easily
resign this position yeah a tough loss
for on drinking I think very very tense
and and high-quality game I mean I am
making about a forty minutes video on
this and if it weren't for another game
of this round which was even more
complicated I could have easily made a
longer one about this very complicated
stuff at the end remember dr.oz got an
important victory for him he really was
on the on the ropes to two losses in
three rounds with two whites were really
ugly score so with the wind now it looks
a little bit more bearable just minus
one and raking our Evers on minus 2 now
and this
it's on last place so I'm relieved bad
start
still it's clear that both players are
not doing their jobs of being Dark
Horse's as I predicted before the
tournament they they seem to struggle
but still they they produce interesting
fighting chess this is important and it
was very interesting to to to watch and
analyze the game as I mentioned easily I
could have made it even more yeah more
extensive this this examination of the
game but ok it's if people want to watch
all the games my coverage it's it's long
enough already and as mentioned there's
another game that even needs some more
attention all right I hope you liked
this coverage and I'll be back tomorrow
of course with the coverage for wrong 5
thanks for watching